nous sommes atteints d'une maladie
maladie dont on ne peut pas guérir même
si on essayait nous avons besoin de ça
pour dire essayer de retrouver la
famille mais pour ça que l'on appelle
déjà ici la pac des vampires
nous avons donc traverser l'atlantique
bien caché mon contact me dis qu'il faut
rouler deux heures vers le nord dans la
campagne il ya un village du monde le
plus on peut lui faire confiance
on n'a pas d'autre choix
on n'était même pas certain qu'il y en
avait d'autres on peut être sûr que tu
n'es pas seul tu es arrivé chez toi
ne fait pas partie de cette famille tu
es faible
qu'est ce que vous avez fait ce défi
je ne sais pas
turow c'est ici